in die uns zuhören oder zuschauen auch
wissen was gefragt worden ist
er will ja guten morgen zusammen
guten morgen vorziehen sehr schön dass
sie dabei sind wie immer gebe ich ihnen
zunächst ein paar daten zur lage
das heißt die meldezahlen das sind wie
immer die offiziell gemeldeten zahlen
wir wissen dass es im internet und in
bestimmten portalen auch andere zahlen
gibt seien sie versichert dass das
robert-koch-institut diese zahlen auch
kennt aber wir beschränken uns auf die
offiziell gemeldeten zahlen weil wir die
trends analysieren und wir sind uns auch
sehr bewusst darüber dass es eine
dunkelziffer gibt das alles sagen wir
immer schon aber es ist nicht immer so
einfach für jeden zu verstehen glauben
sie dass wir dieses business beherrschen
schauen wir uns zunächst mal die
situation in der welt an
wir haben momentan also stand gestern um
15 uhr waren in china insgesamt 41 81
1000 fälle gemeldet
und wir haben international inzwischen
mehr fälle gemeldet außerhalb chinas als
in china
und zwar waren das gestern um 15 uhr
offiziell gemeldet 86 1661 fälle
das betrifft 146 ländern das zeigt also
das was wir ja wissen es handelt sich um
eine pandemie
es handelt sich um ein virus das sich
weltweit verbreitet und das wird es auch
noch einige wochen und monate tun
das wissen wir seit langem und darauf
bereiten wir uns ja auch entsprechend
vor
in italien gibt es bislang 24 1747
offiziell gemeldete fälle
und von diesen haben wir berichtet von
insgesamt 1809 todesfällen also eine
sehr dynamische situation auf der ganzen
welt zurzeit ist tatsächlich europa im
fokus dieser pandemie
hier haben wir die intensiv zur dynamik
und wie gesagt noch einmal hier geht es
um offiziell gemeldete fälle
in südkorea sind mit gestrigem zeitpunkt
15 uhr 8162 fälle gemeldet dass eine
zunahme von knapp 10% gegenüber
vorgestern und hier wurden 75 todesfälle
gemeldet
in deutschland sind die offiziellen
meldezahlen bei 6.012 gestern
sie finden auf der website dass john
hopkins zahl über 7.000 wie gesagt diese
zahlen kennen wir und die berechnen wir
auch in unsere überlegungen mit ein
aber offiziell gemeldet in deutschland
sind 6000 zwölf fälle das sind 6,9
prozent mehr als vorgestern und in
deutschland wurden bisher offiziell
gemeldet 13 todesfälle
ich möchte ein wenig näher auf
deutschland eingehen und noch mal zuerst
ihnen nochmal vermitteln warum wir
risikogebiete definieren weil das auch
in der öffentlichkeit häufig
missverstanden wird
wir bezeichnen als risikogebiet solche
gebiete in denen bestimmte
voraussetzungen gelten die
erkrankungshäufigkeit ist ein indikator
natürlich und zwar die
erkrankungshäufigkeit eben nicht nur an
der reinen zahlen sondern pro kopf
einwohner in der regel brechen dass auf
100.000 die dynamik der täglich
gemeldeten fallzahlen ist ein weiterer
indikator und natürlich auch welche
maßnahmen durchgeführt werden und ein
wichtiger faktor ist ebenfalls auch wie
viele fälle wurden aus der jeweiligen
region quasi in ein anderes land
verbracht das ist ein wichtiger aspekt
der natürlich auch eine rolle spielt all
diese indikatoren berücksichtigen wir
und ich möchte das auch gleich sagen das
ist auch ein dynamisches geschehen und
es ist kann auch der zeitpunkt kommen wo
wir gar keine risikogebiete mehr
definieren wird es einfach zu viele
werden das ist eben in ein rahmen einer
pandemie so und wir passen unsere
bewertungen kontinuierlich wie sie
wissen jeden tag ja an die situation an
stand heute hat das robert-koch-institut
folgende risikogebiete benannt italien
iran in frankreich die region groß
in china die provinz hubei in südkorea
die provinz an book du in österreich das
bundesland tirol in spanien madrid und
in den usa die bundesstaaten kalifornien
washington und new york
und in deutschland haben wir als
besonders betroffenes gebiet was einem
risikogebiet entspricht den landkreis
heinsberg also die pandemie hat eine
große dynamik das wissen sie und das
können sie auch überall lesen
die zahlen der gemälde nimmt also
wirklich sehr sehr stark zu was heißt
das für deutschland noch mal ich betonen
dass gerne nochmal also wir haben
offiziell gemeldet 6012 fälle in baden
württemberg haben wir bislang 1100 fünf
fälle
das ist eine erkrankungsrate von 100 von
9,6 pro 100.000 in hamburg zum beispiel
haben wir 260 fälle stand gestern 15 uhr
jeden tag ändert sich die stand gestern
15 uhr in hamburg 260 fälle das sind
13,9 pro 100000 einwohner nur um ihn ein
beispiel zu geben für die dynamik der
situation und um ihn auch klar zu machen
dass es in verschiedenen regionen
deutschlands unterschiedliche fälle
zahlen gibt unterschiedliche regionen
mit unterschiedlichen dynamiken und das
ist auch immer wichtig zu wissen weil
natürlich in den jeweiligen regionen
dann auch unterschiedlich intensiv
reagiert wird und die ärzte auch
unterschiedlich stark involviert werden
das heißt also wenn wir das vergleichen
die zahlen 15 uhr gestern der stand 6200
gegenüber vorgestern haben wir 1000 174
fälle mehr also eine starke den 766 aber
meiner technik stimmen ach so na ja ich
bin schlechter rechner bitte also ich
lese einfach die zahlen vor
also von diesen 6012 fällen die
offizielle bohr bestätigt sind wurden
5433 aus allen 16 bundesländern an das
robert koch institut übermittelt das
heißt zu diesen zahlen haben wir eben
nicht nur die reinen zahlen sondern auch
informationen zu den patienten die sich
hinter diesen zahlen verbergen
die altersspanne der patienten liegt
zwischen 0 und 95 jahre der alters
median bei 46 jahren und 56 prozent sind
männlich und 44 prozent sind weiblich
wir werden ab morgen um eine leichtere
übersichten zu geben ein sogenanntes
dashboard online stellen das heißt mit
diesem dashboard können sie dann die
tägliche anpassung sehen in deutschland
am 18
dritter wird das dashboard online und
wie gesagt und dann sehen sie doch die
zahlen aber nochmal das sind wirklich
nur die ausschließlich nach
infektionsschutzgesetz übermittelten
fallzahlen diese dynamik ist für uns die
die entscheidende anhand der wir alles
erfassen aber ich sage noch mal die
zahlen von zb dashboard im der johns
hopkins universität werden immer etwas
höher sein
im laufe der nächsten wochen und monate
werden sich diese beiden zahlen aber
immer weiter anpassen
noch ein wort zur lage einschätzung
wir haben heute oder wir werden heute
die risikoeinschätzung für die
gesundheit der bevölkerung in
deutschland ändern
wir werden sie auch heute als hoch
einschätzen
der grund ist ganz einfach sie sehen die
dynamik sie färben unter anderem gestern
bereits hat professor schade ihn auch
vermittelt dass es eine reihe von
hinweisen von lokalen gesundheitsämtern
gibt die von einer sehr dynamischen lage
sprechen
das heißt also das ist der grund warum
einfach noch stärker maßnahmen notwendig
geworden sind um die verbreitung des
virus weiter zu verlangsamen und die
behandlungskapazitäten nicht zu über
nochmal ihnen das ins gedächtnis rufen
seit wochen betreiben wir die strategie
der eindämmung und diese strategie der
eindämmung werden wir immer weiter
betreiben jede infektionskette die wir
unterbrechen können verhindert die
weiterverbreitung des virus aber auch
das habe ich schon mehrfach gesagt wir
werden die verbreitung nicht eindämmen
können wir werden sie nicht stoppen
können
aber wie können sie verlangsamen und das
ist der grund für die maßnahmen die
gestern verkündet wurden der hintergrund
für die geänderte risikoeinschätzung
sind die weiter steigenden fallzahlen
insbesondere die in den vergangenen
tagen vermehrt eingegangenen
alarmsignale aus dem öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und von kliniken auch
wir merken das sogar gut aufgestellte
gesundheitsämter und
universitätskliniken inzwischen probleme
haben mit der steigenden zahl von
erkrankungsfällen darunter sind auch
schwere und teilweise sehr schwere fälle
auf den intensivstationen und es gibt
auch immer mehr fälle momentan die nicht
mehr auf bekannte fälle zurückgeführt
werden können
darum haben wir uns entschlossen die
maßnahmen hatten wir ihnen auch letzte
woche schon berichtet dass wir die
gesundheitsämter unterstützen weiterhin
wir werden studierende ausbilden die bei
der kontakt nach verfolgung helfen
dadurch erhöhen wir die kapazität der
gesundheitsämter will nochmal
wir müssen alles tun um jede mögliche
infektionskette zu unterbrechen und wir
werden das in den nächsten wochen
monaten auch weiterhin tun und wir sind
dabei auch digitale werkzeuge zu
entwickeln um den gesundheitsämtern ihre
arbeit zu beschleunigen und zu
verbessern
wir müssen aber davon ausgehen dass die
tatsächlichen erkrankungszahlen deutlich
höher sind als die geht dem robert koch
institut übermittelt werden
das liegt zum einen an den test
kapazitäten der labore und es liegt
natürlich auch an den übermittlung
kapazitäten durch die gesundheitsämter
denn auch wenn das alles digital erfolgt
muss natürlich irgendwann zu beginn
jemand die daten in die software ein
pflegen das ist ja klar oder im wenn
melde verzug den kennen wir den können
sie auch das sind drei teilweise auch
vier tage
aber die ein die dynamik ist das
entscheidende also dieser melde vorzug
ist uns natürlich auch bekannt und den
planen wir natürlich in unsere
überlegungen mit ein das der grund warum
die gestern verkündeten maßnahmen
getroffen wurden und diese maßnahmen
haben den zweck dass sie die ausbreitung
des virus verlangsamt ohne diese
maßnahmen müssten wir davon ausgehen
dass wir in wenigen monaten vielleicht
mehrere millionen krankheitsfälle haben
und das wollen wir vermeiden und darum
möchte ich alle bitten dass sie diese
maßnahmen ernst nehmen und auch umsetzen
so wie wir das ja seit vielen wochen
wirklich fordern von allen für selber
können einiges tun
durch soziale distanzierung also abstand
die alten durch dadurch dass wir eben in
die armbeuge niesen dass wir ein hygiene
verhalten an den tag legen und virus
nicht weiter tragen
es ist mir auch wichtig zu sagen dass
die gefährdung von region zu region
variiert auch noch mal wichtig zu wissen
das heißt das risiko für die bevölkerung
kann an manchen orten sogar sehr hoch
sein wie das zum beispiel momentan im
land kreis heinsberg gefalle ist die
entscheidende punkt ist der dass die
belastung des gesundheitswesens
maßgeblich davon abhängt und unser
ganzes ziel muss es sein die kapazitäten
des gesundheitswesens so hoch wie
möglich zu fahren uns vorzubereiten
das heißt die kliniken sie vorbereiten
auf eine große zahl von schwer
erkrankten menschen die auch beatmungs
wichtig sind und darum fordern wir seit
wochen die krankenhäusern auf dass sie
ihre kapazitäten hochfahren die intensiv
kapazitäten hochfahren mindestens
verdoppeln und das ist auch machbar das
gelingt auch aber ich möchte noch mal
sagen dass eben wir alle auch durch eine
dadurch dafür abstand halten dass wir
gegebenenfalls wenn es sinnvoll ist in
quarantäne in die verbreitung des virus
verlangsamt die gesundheitsbehörden vor
ort müssen in den nächsten wochen und
monaten weiterhin alles tun um die
eindämmung fortzusetzen ich hatte ihnen
gesagt dass wir sie unterstützen dabei
immer mehr mit allen möglichkeiten ist
wenn viele modelle überlegt und wir
werden die gesundheitsämter weiter
unterstützen
klar ist folgendes jede person die
isoliert wird und jeder enge kontakt in
quarantäne der vermieden wird der
verbreitet die verbreitete verlangsamt
die verbreitung des virus wir müssen
dafür sorge tragen dass nicht zu viele
schwerkranke zur selben zeit ins
krankenhaus müssen und dort
intensivmedizinisch untersucht behandelt
werden müssen
darum auch noch mal wiederholte appell
an alle landrätinnen landräte
bürgermeisterinnen bürgermeister das
sind ja diejenigen die in deutschland
darüber entscheiden wie vor ort mit
patienten mit den gesundheitsämtern
umgegangen wird
sie müssen frühzeitig erkennen wenn sie
hilfe von außen brauchen es gibt ja
genügend möglichkeiten sich von außen
hilfe zu holen sie müssen frühzeitig den
ernst der lage kennen jede ihnen
angeboten unterstützung wahrnehmen
auch die kliniken die bislang noch nicht
so stark betroffenen müssen jetzt jetzt
in diesem moment so wie es am wochenende
auch gefordert wurde von minister sparen
jetzt sich darauf vorbereiten ihre
elektiven operationen runterzufahren und
für die intensivbetten hochzufahren
wir fordern das seit vielen wochen und
nochmal ganz klar haltig wir erwarten
dass von allen hospitälern dass sie ihre
intensiv kapazitäten mindestens
verdoppeln aber lassen sie mich bei all
dem noch einmal die wesentlichen fakten
zu dieser krankheit erläutern
eine von fünf registrierten infizierten
personen wird schwerer erkranken einer
von fünf je nach alter und vorerkrankung
steigt die wahrscheinlichkeit eines
schweren krankheitsverlaufes das heißt
also je älter und je mehr
grundkrankheiten jemand hat ist und je
mehr grundkrankheiten jemand hat desto
größer ist das risiko für ihn schwer zu
erkranken
wir wissen dass eben auch menschen an
dieser krankheit versterben
es wird also todesfälle geben und es
wird auch in deutschland weiterhin
gestiegene zahl von todesfällen
aber vier von fünf registrierten
infizierten werden nur leichte symptome
erfahren sie werden nach abklingen der
infektion gesund sein und sie bilden
immunität gegen das virus aus wir wissen
noch nicht wie die sterberate am ende
aussehen durch das wissen wir einfach
nicht aber wenn sie einmal zahlen die in
den letzten wochen immer wieder
kursieren nehmen wir eine zahl von einem
prozent der registrierten dann heißt das
ja dass 99 prozent der registrierten das
überleben
ja ich bitte sie das auch immer klar vor
augen zu haben
also selbst wenn die sterblichkeit so
hoch wäre wie ein prozent dann wurden 99
prozent die krankheit überleben lassen
wir noch betonen
das ist wichtig die ärztinnen und ärzte
die ja veranlassen wenn jemand getestet
werden soll oder nicht müssen sich bitte
nach den empfehlungen richten wir müssen
die tests sehr strategisch einsetzen
wir können diese krise nur gut
überstehen wenn wir alle einen kühlen
kopf bewahren
das tun was sie tun können um die
verbreitung einzudämmen
und dazu gehört auch dass ärztinnen und
ärzte dann patienten testen wenn es
geboten ist
tests müssen strategisch eingesetzt
werden denn ansonsten ist natürlich auch
die aussagekraft der zahlen die wir
haben gar nicht so leicht das heißt also
es gibt klare empfehlung von uns waren
zu testen ist oder nicht getestet werden
muss wir haben am rk ii mit einem
innovativen ansatz und auch einem sehr
praxisorientierten ansatz
einige der publikationen bislang dazu
nutzen können
die schweren krankheitsverläufe besser
vorherzusagen
das ist ganz wichtig dass mit wir das
einschätzen können und wir wir sehen wir
haben einige werkzeuge entwickelt in den
letzten jahren die habe ich auch schon
mal vor gezeugt vorgestellt sind drei
werkzeuge neben den reinen meldezahlen
die ich ihn mal vermelden
eines ist das krippe web wo wir viele
tausend mit nutzer haben die dadurch
angeben was für krankheits symptome so
haben dadurch kann man sehr schön sehen
wie die krankheitslast in deutschland
ist wie sich die atemwegsinfektion
entwickeln wenn mein zweites tool wo wir
über sentinel praxen das sind also rund
sechs bis sieben 100 praxen in
deutschland von denen rund 100 immer so
proben einsendern unser labor so dass
wir jeden tag tausende von proben
teilweise untersuchen die untersuchen
wir auf das vorkommen von bestimmten
viren durch haben wir jetzt auch die
ersten kroner wie ein gefühl und wir
haben ein weiteres werkzeug mit dem wir
den anteil der schwer erkrankten jungen
erkrankten in den krankenhäusern messen
können mit all diesen tools sehen wir
wie sich die krankheitslast entwickelt
und können dadurch sehr gut einschätzen
wie der krankheitsverlauf ist und
dadurch natürlich auch steuernd
eingreifen
ich habe ihn gestern auch eine
entschuldigung ich glaube das war am
freitag habe ich ihnen auch mitgeteilt
dass wir zusammen mit zwei
gesellschaften ein werkzeugen entwickelt
haben mit dem man die intensivbetten
sehr gut monitoren kann sodass man also
weiß welche krankenhäuser haben noch
intensivbetten kapazitäten frei welche
nicht das ist ein werkzeug das zunehmend
ausgerollt wird das sehr wichtig sein
wird wenn dann strategisch patienten
bestimmten kliniken zu bestimmten
kliniken gebracht werden
das heißt wir brauchen viele von diesen
werkzeugen um wirklich optimal das
gesundheitssystem zu nutzen
das tun wir alles gemeinsam mit dem
gesundheitssystem um die anzahl der
patienten die gut versorgt werden können
hochzuhalten in der zukunft aber ich
möchte auch noch mal sagen dass
natürlich die bürgerinnen und bürger
vieles dazu tun können wie wir das seit
drei wochen glaube ich mache jetzt das
pressebriefing etwa sagen bitte halten
sie abstand bitte halten sie quarantäne
ein wenn sie denn auferlegt wird vom
gesundheitsamt sorgen sie dafür dass
wenn sie erkrankt sind sie in ihre
armbeuge niesen dass das virus nicht
über ihre hände weitergetragen wird
waschen sie sich die hände waschen sich
die hände intensiv so oft sie können und
wenn sie das nicht können keine
gelegenheit haben nehmen sie sich an
desinfektionsmittel in der tasche mit
ihnen können sie ihre hände
desinfizieren
ich würde es nochmal sagen dass die
meisten ja nur mild
aber wir müssen immer im auge haben dass
wir viele schwer erkrankte haben die wir
behandeln werden wollen weiterhin
behandeln wollen darum müssen die
epidemie verlangsamt je mehr wir sie
verlangsamen mit den maßnahmen die ich
ihn vorgestellt hat desto mehr können
wir gut versorgen
dafür tragen wir alle zusammen die
verantwortung wie man so schön sagt mit
heißem herz aber kühlem kopf
das müssen wir von uns allen abverlange
und das können ja noch das heißt also
jeder einzelne kann wirklich etwas dazu
tun alle die maßnahmen die wir seit
wochen ihn nennen auch ganz bewusst
durchzuhalten
wir werden diesen weg der strategischen
bekämpfung von kogit 19 weitergehen und
dazu gehört ist eben auch eine
verantwortungsbewusste kommunikation
durchzuführen auch eine transparente
information so wie wir das seit wochen
tun und auch weiterhin tun werden und
wir brauchen natürlich eine klare
sachliche risikoanalyse auch dass das
können sie dessen können sich versichert
sein werden wir in den nächsten wochen
und monaten tun
klar ist dass wir wirklich alle viel
solidarität zeigen sollten in den
nächsten wochen und monaten
und ich bin auch sehr zuversichtlich
dass wir das tun würden
dankeschön vielen dank fragen sie und
wie gesagt relativ laut sprechen und ich
wiederhole es dann kurz damit die
zuhörer das auch
doch relativ wieder ausgleicht unseren
baumarkt reicht das aus und die zweite
frage mich anschließen würde und zehn
tagen wenn man der agent müsse sehen
werden was muss ich denn da entwickeln
nach ihrer sicht ja ganz kurz die
wiederholung für die idee uns online
oder beim fernsehen zu schauen
es ist gefragt worden wie die maßnahmen
der bundesregierung eingesetzt werden
das gäbe viele ausnahmen und dann noch
die frage wie man man die ersten
ergebnisse sieht von diesen maßnahmen
oder positiven entwicklung also das
rationale ist ja ganz einfach wenn ich
glaube da haben wir auch öfter schon
darüber diskutiert hier in diesem forum
und auch sie sicher auch schon mit
freunden und bekannten
je weniger intensive kontakte man zu
anderen personen hat desto schwerer wird
es dem virus gemacht sich auszubreiten
insofern sind das absolut absolut
angemessene maßnahmen ja wann wir sehen
werden ob diese maßnahmen greifen wie
sie greifen
das hängt in erster linie von einer zahl
ab die wir ja als inkubationszeit
inkubationszeit benennen wir haben ja
eine inkubationszeit von etwa 14 tagen
das heißt also das ist eine maß größe
die wir mal so im kopf haben
ob das stimmt werden wir sehen aber klar
ist dass wir natürlich an dem verlauf
der meldezahlen und an dem was wir
messen in deutschland an dem verlauf der
schweren krankheitsfällen einschätzen
können ob diese maßnahmen greifen oder
nicht sie sind sinnvoll und deshalb bin
ich optimistisch dass sie dazu beitragen
dass wir uns zu verlangsamen dennoch mal
das virus von mensch zu mensch
übertragen das heißt also wenn ich die
menschlichen kontakte reduzieren wird es
dem virus schwer macht sich zu
verbreiten
die nachbarländer gleichzeitig stehen
fest
wie sie gestern noch kurz die
wiederholung die frage ob deutschland
die regierung zu langsam reagiert die
drastischen maßnahmen machen die anderen
immer zuerst fragezeichen also ich kann
das nicht beurteilen ob alle anderen
länder immer alles zuerst machen aber
klar ist folgendes das habe ich auch
versucht zu vermitteln in den letzten
wochen
es ist wichtig immer eine lage
einschätzung zu haben
und wir haben ja wirklich belastbare
informationen dass wir einfach diese
erkrankungen oder die den ausbruch die
epidemie in deutschland sehr früh
erkannt haben und dadurch auch zeit
hatten bestimmte maßnahmen in die wege
zu leiten
ich halte das für angemessen und ich
auch ganz offen gesagt wir werden ja
dann wenn diese epidemie vorbei ist
werden viele menschen im hinter hinein
schauen was alles geschehen ist man wird
es dann bewerten wir tun alle das beste
was wir können und ich kann mir auch
vorstellen dass durchaus das eine oder
andere vielleicht im nachhinein als
hätte vielleicht besser sein können
lassen sie uns wenn diese epidemie
vorbei ist kritisch überschauen
ich halte es für angemessen
denken wir dass die maßnahme zu prüfen
eine neue aktion wohl ja also was ist
der status im moment die kontrolle ist
und nicht noch mal ganz kurz die frage
wie lange gefragt wurde wie lange es
dauert bis die pandemie wirklich vorbei
ist oder die erste welle vorbei ja ich
wünschte ich könnte ihnen diese frage
sagt die nicht beantworten wir gehen von
all oder sagen wir wir hier im institut
und wir sind ja mit vielen fachleuten
international sehr eng verbunden
nehmen wir nur ein beispiel ich selber
bin in einem beratergremium wir sind
etwa zwölf wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die auf die welt
verteilt sind wie berater mike ryan das
ist ja der chef des welt der world als
im mercy programmes das ist einer der
menschen auf der welt für die ich die
größte hochachtung habe ein
fantastischer krisenmanager der der sein
ganzes leben dar einsetzt und ich hoffe
nur dass er dass er diesen ganzen stress
übersteht so wie wir sind sehr sehr gut
informiert wir gehen davon aus und das
haben wir ja auch hier schon häufiger
gesagt dass wir von zwei jahren sagen
wir mal ob wir ihn von jahren waren
diese pandemie vielleicht einmal um die
welt gegangen ist pandemien verlaufen in
wellen
das wissen wir das ist sicher aber wie
schnell diese wellen sind und wann dann
diese von denen wir immer sprechen 60
bis 70 prozent der person weltweit der
menschen weltweit infiziert ist das wird
jahre dauern sagen ich hatte mal eine
zahl von mehr als zwei jahre aber das
hängt natürlich dann auch stark davon ab
wann wir den impfstoff einsetzen können
ist ja klar
jede intervention zu möglichkeit die uns
an die hand gegeben wird ist natürlich
hilfreich und die früher ein impfstoff
kommen desto schneller wird dann auch
die pandemie eingegrenzt werden können
aber nur weil ein impfstoff da ist heißt
es ja auch noch nicht dass alle menschen
geimpft werden ja es gibt ja kapazitäten
von impfstoffen und wir müssen ja auch
geimpft wären das heißt wir werden auch
sehr viele menschen haben wir ja 99
prozent von allen registrierten sind
haben das ja überstanden haben eine
immunität wir wissen ja auch nach den
heutigen kenntnissen die wir haben ist
es so dass wir vielleicht die hälfte von
allen die infiziert werden überhaupt
krank werden dass der status heute es
gibt kaum eine infektionskrankheit wohl
jeder der infiziert wird krank wird bei
diesem virus scheint es so zu sein nach
dem heutigen wissen dass etwa die hälfte
überhaupt nur krank wenn das heißt die
andere hälfte sehen wir ja gar nicht die
sind infiziert haben nichts gemerkt
haben die immunität ja also wir reden
auch über monate wir gehen auf einem
zeitraum von zwei jahren aus
gefragt wurde wann der impfstoff zur
verfügung stehen könnte also ich gleich
beantworten ja also ich gehe nach wie
vor davon aus dass es gibt ja folgendes
zu verstehen im stoffe haben wir ja
schon häufig gesagt die werden sehr
schnell fertig sein also werden in
wenigen wochen werden wir
impfstoffkandidaten haben aber
impfstoffe müssen ja erst immer getestet
werden das heißt es gibt es zwei dinge
die uns interessieren als als
wissenschaftler aber auch als
verantwortungsträger die dann einen
solchen impfstoff federn zu lassen
der wird dann irgendwann an menschen
dann eben auch angewendet das ist das
profil bezogen auf den schutz also wie
gut schützt der impfstoff das muss man
ja auch austesten und das zweite was
aber genauso wichtig ist es eben ist ja
auch sicher es gibt ja prinzipiell die
möglichkeit von nebenwirkungen und die
muss man natürlich austesten und wenn
man den nebenwirkungen austestet dann
kann man das auch nicht von einem tag
auf den andern tun sondern das braucht
auch ein paar wochen bis man das
beobachtet das heißt also die ganzen
klinischen testungen die werden nach wie
vor wochen lang dauern
aber was ich weiß und was ich was sehr
erfreulich ist ist in den letzten jahren
hat die internationale gemeinschaft
schon ist schon sehr viel
zusammengerückt und haben sehr viel
mechanismen entwickelt um alles zu
beschleunigen und auch gerade die
zulassungsbehörde ja unheimlich wichtig
sind dass eben kein keine medikamente
auf den markt kommen die eben nicht
seriösen unternehmen wirken haben auch
die können bestimmte verfahren
beschleunigen
aber ich bin trotzdem davon überzeugt
dass ein impfstoff erst anfangen erst im
nächsten jahr zur verfügung steht
jeder monat ich sage also vor frühem
nächsten jahr kann ich persönlich ist
nicht an ihm aber jeden monat um nehme
ich mich hier freue ich mich natürlich
ja klar
wäre werden bewegungsdaten von
komapatienten jetzt ausgewertet und das
handelsblatt meldet das robert koch
institut würde sowas auch erwähnen
dies wurde gefragt ob bewegungsdaten
ausgewertet werden ja also wir halten
das für ein sinnhaftes konzept ja es
gibt da verschiedene aspekte abzuwägen
die kennen sie alles gibt datenschutz
aspekte es gibt technische aspekte ich
sag nur soviel hier
ich bin nach meinem kenntnisstand davon
überzeugt dass beide aspekte bewältigt
werden können
und der vorteil wäre natürlich dass wir
die gesundheitsämter enorm unterstützen
sie müssen sich ja vorstellen wie
geschieht die kontakt nachverfolgung das
ist so dass ein patient wird
diagnostiziert dass er ein fall ist also
er hat einen positiven testergebnis und
dann ist die aufgabe des
gesundheitsamtes mit dieser person zu
sprechen sie zu interviewen und zu
fangen mit wem hattest du dein kontakt
intensiven in den letzten beiden wochen
um dann risikopatienten zu
identifizieren die dann wiederum befragt
werden und je nachdem wir haben ja
verschiedene kategorien ist ja ganz
strategisch ganz logisch aufgebaut oder
wenn man eine sehr enge kontaktpersonen
war dann wäre man eine person des gerade
ist eins der kategorie eins dann sollte
man den häusliche quarantäne gehen und
so weiter also verschiedene verschiedene
maßnahmen und das ist natürlich ein 1 1
ein prozess der eine zeit in der zeit
kostet wenn sie sich vorstellen dass es
möglich wäre herauszufinden anhand einer
bestimmten applikation wer denn in den
letzten zwei wochen in einer bestimmten
entfernung und für eine bestimmte zeit
in dieser entfernung gewesen wäre dann
wäre das natürlich zielgenauer diese
personen direkt zu kontaktieren und ich
sage nochmal das ist technisch möglich
und es ist auch datenschutzrechtlich
möglich ich bin sehr optimistisch
dass uns das gelingen wird und wir
arbeiten daran mit einem team die alle
ein team von 25 leuten die auf zwölf
verschiedenen institutionen kommen und
die dass alle seit drei wochen wirklich
sieben tage die woche bearbeiten ohne
dafür bislang auch nur annähernd
irgendwelche entlohnung bekommen zu
haben sind alles menschen die diesem
land dienen wollen die solidarität in
hohem maße aufbauen und ich bin sehr
optimistisch dass das gelingt wir werden
das jedes liegt nicht in meiner hand
alleine aber ich bin sehr optimistisch
dass wir ein überzeugendes konzept haben
während kurz
wenn sie das ganz stringent durch denken
wäre das eine logik wir werden sehen wie
stark wir es eingrenzen können und dann
wird man sehen wie die massnahmen
angepasst werden das ist wirklich eine
betrachtungsweise die wir kontinuierlich
durch für müssen ja wie gesagt eben im
im extremen fall bestünde diese
möglichkeit wir werden sie in ob es so
ist
ich kann die frage noch mal wiederholen
aber es ist tatsächlich nichts zu tun
es ging um die frage ob die amerikaner
sich impfstoffe sichern können oder
rechte an impfstoffen sichern
also jede maßnahme die nicht solidarisch
ist bewerte ich natürlich als
unsolidarisch ja wenn es diese versuch
tatsächlich gegeben hat dann dann ist
das bedauerlich
mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen ich weiß
nur dass die firma zu weg ein sehr
innovatives produkt hat nämlich das geht
es um folgendes sie entwickeln und da
sind sich die einzige firma es gibt auch
eine andere firma die dieses bunten oder
diesem diese möglichkeit hat eine andere
firma die das auch kann der impfstoff
funktioniert folgendermaßen das ist ein
sehr innovatives projekt aber ich muss
dazu sagen es gibt bislang keinen
zugelassenen impfstoff da also ob das
projekt gelingt werden wir sehen
es geht darum dass man eben nicht den
konventionellen impfstoff anwendet also
man initiiert quasi teile von einem
virus in dem falle damit der körper
gegen dieses virus dann eine immunität
auf gibt es 22 arme der immunität des
eine sind die die antikörper das andere
sind die t zellen und und viel besser
man diese immunität anwirft desto
stärker ist der schutz
hier ist das konzept ein anderes und das
konzept wurde eben schon erfolgreich in
der tumortherapie angewendet hier wird
eine also einfach nur rna also gen
material wird injiziert und dieses gen
material wird gezielt in bestimmte
zellen geschleust und diese zellen
werden dann quasi dazu aktiviert sofort
gegen die von dem genmaterial gebilden
stoffe proteine des virus eine
immunantwort zu starten und das ist das
innovative das heißt die ganze natur zum
einen sehr sehr gezielt aktiviert und
zum anderen auch schneller aktiviert
dieses konzept hat in der onkologie ist
es bereits angewendet es hat dort
erfolge gezeigt
darum sind viele wissenschaftler
hoffnungsfroh dass das auch für einen
impfstoff sein wird aber bislang muss
ich sagen sind es eben vorwiegend
versuche im tiermodell wir werden
schauen ob sich dieser impfstoff
durchsetzt wenn wäre es großartig weil
es
schnell ist weil es effizient ist und
weil es sogar auch kostengünstig ist
also es ist schon es ist ein sehr
innovatives konzept aber wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass es eben noch excel
ist und wir müssen eben auch die
konventionellen impfstoffe
da gibt es ja auch tolle modelle ohne
das jetzt im detail zu vertiefen
wir müssen natürlich auch dafür sorge
tragen dass die konventionelle im stoffe
die auch sehr innovativ sind ebenfalls
weiter untersucht werden
dafür braucht es dann eben einen
internationalen mechanismus irgendwann
muss man dann ja quasi entscheiden
welchen impfstoff wird man dann jetzt
präferieren und in die produktion
bringen
darum ist die internationale
zusammenarbeit so weit und da kann ich
ihnen nur versichern dass eben auch die
wissenschaftler international dort eine
hohe solidarität haben ausgangssperre zu
rechnen
die hochstufung frucht der die maßnahmen
wurden ja gestern verkündet also ich
kann nur alle wirklich darum dazu
ermahnen oder ermuntern dass sie die
maßnahmen die gestern genannt wurden
dass die eingehalten werden ja ganz
einfach
das heißt das öffentliche leben ist
eingeschränkt weniger mobilität weniger
kontakt zu anderen menschen das bedeutet
dass die risikoabschätzung auf
hochgestuft wird
ja sehr hoch ja mehr stufen haben wir
nicht zu vergeben
sie hatten noch dahin es gibt 128 1034
fahren gibt es denn eine alternative
muss jeder ein krankenhaus muss wirklich
intensiv welt gekommen die frage ob
jeder kranke der ins krankenhaus kommt
ein intensiv mit braucht und ob man das
verdoppeln kann
also wer intensivmedizinisch behandelt
werden muss können ja nur die ärzte vor
ort entscheiden das ist ja klar aber es
gibt noch menge möglichkeiten um die
anzahl der betten zu erhöhen
es gibt viele möglichkeiten die ich im
einzelnen gar nicht kenne aber ich
spreche auch mit klinikchefs mit ärzten
es gibt noch eine reihe von
möglichkeiten die aufzustocken
und es gibt natürlich auch einfache
verhältnisse einfach betten die man
aufbauen kann und wo man beatmung
durchführen kann ohne dass man den
normalen standard den wir in kliniken
zur zeit sehe neben dann noch fahren
könnten das ist ja auch klar sie
erinnern sich vielleicht an die kliniken
die in haan aufgebaut wurden in sehr
sehr kurzer zeit
das waren auch sehr sehr einfache
räumlichkeiten aber sie diente neben
dazu patienten atmen zu können
und das ist natürlich möglich also wir
haben hier noch möglichkeiten die
kapazitäten zu erhöhen
strategisch gut was bedeutet dass es
gibt immer weniger leute über lange
wartezeiten
das wäre die erste frage selbst
angezeigt
für die zuhörer
was bedeutet das dass die test
strategisch eingesetzt werden sollen und
die frage was alarm ein alarmzeichen bei
uns eingegangen ist ja also wir haben
ich will das noch mal kurz einmal den
ablauf
was wir hier am robert-koch-institut tun
warum wir das tun seit dem 6 januar also
jetzt das sind jetzt schon das sind zwei
monaten also am sechsten januar
das ist drei mal seit dem letzten januar
arbeiten wir mit einer arbeitsgruppe die
das geschehen betrachtet vierzehnter
januar haben wir das erhöht haben wir
also mehr mitarbeiter quasi mit der
analyse der der deutschen und der
internationale befasst dann hatten wir
den ersten fall in deutschland das war
der 27 januar
da hatten wir den ausbruch den wir in
bayern hatten und und die zwei
repatriierten die in frankfurt behandelt
wurde übrigens alle kerngesund
inzwischen die 16 haben ja alle überlebt
und sind kerngesund
die 16 personen die wir damals in
deutschland als erste identifiziert
hatten
und dann kam die fälle in heimsheim und
das heißt wir arbeiten an der zeit
diesen monaten arbeiten wir intensiv
daran empfehlungen zu erstellen und die
empfehlungen sind ja zunächst mal unsere
empfehlungen sind der für ärzte wir sind
dafür da den ärzten in deutschland eine
handreichung zu geben wie sie sich zu
verhalten haben
wir brauchen sie brauchen empfehlungen
was soll ich tun einrahmen den
einzelfall muss natürlich jeder einzelne
immer noch regeln aber wir geben
empfehlungen und die empfehlungen die
wir unter anderem erarbeitet haben ist
ein flussdiagramm wir inzwischen so
viele empfehlungen das ist ein riesen
dokumenten schrank geworden und wir
haben unter anderem einfluss schema
entwickelt wir entwickeln fluss schemata
nicht um jeden einzelfall zu regeln
sondern um das prinzip zu vermitteln und
nehmen wir ein beispiel jemand war in
einem risikogebiet der grund warum wir
risikogebiete definieren hatte ich
gerade diese vier kriterien
jemand war in einem risikogebiet er
kommt zurück nach hause und er erkrankt
er kriegt schnupfen husten fieber
wenn er jetzt in einem risikogebiet
gewesen ist dann ist ja die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass er vielleicht
angesteckt wurde größer als wenn er
nicht in einem risikogebiet gewesen wäre
das heißt also da hat zum beispiel ein
arzt von uns die empfehlung bekommen den
sollte er testen wenn aber irgendjemand
gar nicht in einem risikogebiet war und
leichte symptome hat dann ist ja die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass er dass die
infektion hat geringer dann muss er
nicht getestet werden das meine ich mit
strategisch da gibt es eine menge andere
punkte die können sie sich auch noch mal
gerne anschauen auf diesen auf diesem
fluss schemata oder es gibt dann im
rahmen von ausbruchs untersuchen die das
gesundheitsamt durchführt da gibt es
eben auch bestimmte menschen die man
kategorisiert einfach risikokategorie 1
die müssen getestet werden und so weiter
das heißt also dass man nicht mit
strategisch warum ist das so wichtig
dann geht es zum einen natürlich um die
kapazität ja wir haben die kapazität ist
in deutschland sehr sehr groß wir können
über 160.000 tests machen pro woche etwa
und das kann man auch noch steigern
aber es ist natürlich klar dass es
personen gibt die aus den ganzen
epidemiologischen überlegungen die wir
ja machen vielleicht eher getestet
werden sollten als andere und das ist
strategisch der das heißt also die ärzte
haben mir auch die pflicht das zu
klassifizieren und die zu testen von
denen sie denken bei denen macht es mehr
sind oder nicht das ist nichts weiter
als die ärztliche fürsorgepflicht
schauen sie stellen sich vor es gäbe
dieses cockpit 19 nicht
und die gehen mit atemwegserkrankungen
zum arzt
ja dann geht der arzt schaut sie an
macht eine anamnese und sagt ob die ok
gehen wir nach hause bleibt man eine
woche zu hause ich verschreibt ihr dies
oder jenes und guck mal wie es
weitergeht
oder er sagt das hier sieht aber nach
einer schweren erkrankung aus dass
könnten influenza anlass uns man
influenza test machen ja dass die
differentialdiagnose dass das ist der
job der täglich job eines jeden gastes
hierzu mit dem patienten umzugehen ihnen
entweder zu sagen gehabt zu hause das
kannst du aus oder ich weise dich ins
krankenhaus ein und mache die sozial
diagnose oder nicht das ist alltag
unabhängig von kurven 19 dafür sind
ärzte ausgebildet und wir geben ihnen
empfehlungen wie sie diese werkzeuge die
ihnen zur verfügung stehen strategisch
nutzen
alarmzeichen kliniken heißt das eben die
anzahl der schwer kranken zunimmt
das heißt also hinzu sie haben zunehmend
patienten die eben intensivmedizinisch
betreut werden müssen beatmet werden
müssen das heißt die fallzahlen nehmen
zu so wie das ja auch zu erwarten ist
wie sagen wir seit wochen dass wir am
beginn einer epidemie stehen das heißt
die zahlen nähmen zu die zahlen der
schwerkranken nehmen zu die zahlen der
verstorbenen nehmen zu und das heißt
dass in bestimmten kliniken dass die das
schon sehen und uns auch spiegeln dass
die epidemie eben angekommen ist und das
wichtige ist eben es gibt regionen wo
das eben gar nicht so ist
es gibt regionen in deutschland wo diese
krankheit überhaupt keine rolle spielt
in der wahrnehmung der öffentlichkeit
oder der krankenhäuser
aber sie wird auch dahin kommen und
darum sagen wir alle krankenhäuser
müssen